new polling shows democrats behind on
nearly every major issue
democrats can't stop doubling down on
stupid and america's spoiled brats are
on the march i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
well we keep hearing that inflation is
transitory it's not going to be a big
deal there's only one problem
um it doesn't seem super transitory at
this point in time plus
joe biden's plan is to spend more money
than has ever yet been created in the
history of humanity and then raise taxes
to boot so
if you are looking to diversify your
income streams and ensure that your
savings are protected
you might want to look at birch gold in
april alone consumer prices increased by
4.2 percent that was the biggest bump
since 2008
higher fuel prices higher food prices
construction cost housing prices
inflation is here have you protected
your savings your investments if you've
not yet diversified a portion into
precious metals the answer is
new so i'm gonna tell you again if you
haven't reached out to my friends at
birch gold to diversify part of your ira
or 401k into a precious metals ira
do it today text ben 247 47 47 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings
with gold i buy my gold from birch gold
because they have an a plus rating with
the better business bureau countless
five-star reviews over ten thousand
happy customers talk to them
ask them all your questions and then
once you feel secure have them help you
safeguard your savings at least a little
bit tech spends 47 47 47
when you make a purchase before june
30th birch gold will send you a signed
copy of my book how to destroy america
in three easy steps for free
while supplies last again text spend 247
47 protect your savings today alrighty
so
democrats have a real problem here the
problem is people don't actually like
what it is that they are selling
according to axios over the weekend
the democratic messaging group future
majority in may released a deck
identifying areas where republicans hold
an advantage ready for this of the
issues polled
defunding the police open borders and
reparations for slavery were by far the
biggest turn-offs for both independents
and voters in general
and so all of those have to do with the
democrats racial equity program
the suggestion that america is deeply
unjust requires
that we get rid of the police or defund
the police or defang the police we have
to have open borders as some sort of
guilt notion on behalf of the united
states and reparations for slavery of
course is deeply tied into the idea that
america remains systemically racist
and that all inequalities of outcome are
due to historic grievances republicans
however didn't just stop there
they also bested democrats again this is
according to future majority a
democratic messaging group
republicans also bested democrats on
jobs in the economy
gun rights and keeping you and your
family safe so all the things right
those are all the issues there are no
other issues
maybe democrats best republicans unlike
climate change which is america's 97th
concern considering it is a thing that
is going to happen over the course of a
century we still don't know
exactly how much human activities have
contributed to it and even if we did
we don't really know how to handle it
aside from taking some sort of
adaptation measures according to axios
the poll future majority wrote in its
report on the finding shows voters
especially independents
believe the democrats overspend as well
so this means that democrats have
overstepped on nearly every aspect of
their agenda but the problem is this for
the democrats they cannot stop the
overstep they cannot it is too deeply
rooted
to their core ideology democrats made a
shift between 2010
and 2012. and that shift was they were
going to move away from broadcasting and
instead they were going to start narrow
casting
barack obama did in fact transform the
united states he did so in
extraordinarily negative ways
not through kind of joe biden or fdr or
lbj spending programs alone it wasn't
just obamacare
it was how he shifted the notion of how
american politics was done
instead of american politics being a
battle between two sides
sort of locked down their base and then
move out to the middle and try and
approach the middle instead
american politics became a game in which
you reached out to very specific
slices of particular demographics and
then you gave them giveaways goodies
almost as though you were trying to put
together some sort of omnibus package
in the senate right where you give
somebody a path here and there's some
log rolling here
instead it was an intersectional
coalition that was brought together only
by opposition
to that evil right wing and and barack
obama was very clear about this in 2010
and 2012
in 2008 when barack obama was elected he
was elected on the basis of
broadcasting right casting to the
broadest possible net
and then after 2008 when he became
president and there was opposition to
the
to his program from the tea party when
he lost congress in 2010
when he took as he said a shellacker
when that happened
suddenly his mindset shifted because it
was not a rebuke to his program after
all barack obama was too brilliant
and god like a figure for people to
rebuke his agenda if you
ever read or listen to anything obama
says the problem was never his agenda it
was
always how he expressed his agenda right
he just wasn't able to get across he
from on high the zeus-like figure was
unable to cast his
thunderbolts of joy in such a way that
the american public were capable of
receiving it it was always a messaging
problem
and so instead he he interpreted his own
failures and the failures of his
political program to be popular he
interpreted that as american racism as
deep-seated american bigotry despite the
fact that the overwhelming majority of
american voters in 2008
elected him until he immediately began
trying to cobble together a coalition
that was rooted in the idea that there
was an ascendant demographic minority
that was eventually going to be
a demographic majority and simply swamp
the right
and donald trump was a reaction to that
if there is a racial aspect to america's
politics which undoubtedly at this point
unfortunately there is
it was not started by donald trump it
was started by barack obama and
democrats who declared overtly and
repeatedly
and and thinkers like ronald brownstein
who repeatedly said that there was this
demographic minority that was going to
swamp the white demographic majority and
that the browning of america
inevitably meant the making democrat of
america now that isn't true it's a lie
in fact as you see in the last election
cycle
republicans are starting to make inroads
into browner and browner communities as
florida has gotten demographically
browner it has also gotten
demographically more republican because
it turns out
that race is not in fact destiny it
turns out the demographics are not
actually destiny right people can change
their minds people change how they think
people even change how they think of
themselves which is why there are two
categories
on the american census hispanic and then
whether you think of yourself as
hispanic or whether you think of
yourself
as white right people think of
themselves in different racial
categories sort of depending
on how they think about themselves but
democrats don't believe that they have a
racially essentialist viewpoint
right that is in fact rooted and as
we've been discussing critical race
theory
this idea that there are certain
essentials to being black or essential
to being asian or essential to being
anything with regard to ethnicity and
this separates you off from the white
demographic majority and therefore you
are part of the intersectional coalition
now if you reject that then you have
rejected your own racial essentialism
and this means that you're a self-hating
black person if you're clarence thomas
or
it means that you're a self-age a
self-hating asian person if you don't
side
with this coalition of the ascendant
okay well what this means that democrats
are deeply wedded to this program
because again
they have pegged all of their hopes for
future success not on the popularity
of their actual political programs you
can see this throughout
right democrats are being handed whole
after poll showing people don't like
their policies on crime
they're being shown poll after poll that
americans do not like their policies
with regard to the border
poll after poll that americans are not
interested in their policies with regard
to
racial reparations and new racial new
forms of racial discrimination americans
just don't like it but they cannot let
go of it because to let go of it would
mean
to let go of the new vision of politics
wrought by barack obama
and to go back to the old vision of
politics in which he had to forge
consensus and find common policy
it was a more clintonian notion of how
politics was done barack obama's notion
was if i forge
enough of a core i can just do whatever
the hell i want and you see that this is
how
democrats are playing this thing out and
so they've been militarizing the
american government and weaponizing the
american government
in ways that frankly would have made
donald trump blush we heard
over and over and over that bill barr
was simply a partisan on behalf of
donald trump
now we know that's not true we do bill
bart repeatedly
did not do what trump wanted him to do
trump obviously wanted him
to initiate some sort of prosecution
against
hillary clinton right jeff sessions was
pressured to do that jeff sessions was
pressured to intervene with regard to
the russian collusion
investigation right his attorneys
general donald trump
i've never seen an administration where
the president was so in conflict with
his own attorneys general to the point
where president trump was constantly
ripping on his original a.g jeff
sessions and suggesting that he was not
loyal
in fact by the end of his term in office
a.g sessions by the time that sessions
left trump was ripping him so often
that sessions couldn't even go back to
his seat in the senate in alabama and
said tommy tuberville took over his seat
in alabama because trump overtly
endorsed his opponent
same thing with bill barr right bill
barr started off and trump
was in love with the guy and then by the
end of his tenure trump hated the guy
right there's there's a new piece in the
atlantic talking about
william barr and trump and how bar was
telling trump pretty overtly
that all of the election fraud stuff was
overblown and that in fact
he had lost the election and trump was
very angry at him over all of this not
so with democrats
this is why it was so galling to watch
democrats in the media suggest that bill
barr
was some sort of cat's paw for trump
that he was just doing whatever trump
wanted it was so clearly untrue but i'll
tell you who is doing that
the great and heralded merrick garland
r.i.p
because he never made it on the supreme
court but merrick garland is the new
attorney general
so over the weekend he announced a
lawsuit against the state of georgia
now the only reason is this is partisan
politics the doj
is being weaponized against police
departments around the nation again on
the basis of this racial equity campaign
that has nothing to do with reality and
in fact
undermines the safety and security of
americans particularly minority
americans the doj is being weaponized
against police departments all over the
country as we'll get to
and the doj is now being used as a legal
cudgel
against states that do not see voting in
the same way the democrats wish to see
voting
namely ballot harvesting no id loosening
all the requirements to allow for the
possibility of stuffing the ballot box
and voter fraud right so georgia passes
this voter law remember georgia's voter
law is still more permissive
than voter laws in joe biden's home
state of delaware is still more
permissive than the voter laws in places
i believe like new jersey and new york
it doesn't matter merrick garland
is now using in highly partisan fashion
the department of justice
to go after the state of georgia and
this is nothing new eric holder
proclaimed himself barack obama's
wingman while he was a.g
no one batted and i both jeff sessions
and bill barr were directly at odds with
trump
over and over and over again because
trump was repeatedly asking them to do
things that did not comply
with their oath of office and they just
rejected it here's merrick garland
rejecting his own off of office okay
there's no grounds for this lawsuit
against georgia
at all i've read the lawsuit against
georgia it doesn't make any sense it's
gonna get laughed out of court
if there is a judge with half a brain
nonetheless here is the great and
heralded bipartisan figure merrick
garland
just doing the bidding of the biden
administration
today the department of justice is suing
the state of georgia
our complaint alleges that recent
changes to georgia's election laws
were enacted with the purpose of denying
or abridging the right of black
georgians
to vote on account of their race or
color in violation of section two
of the voting rights act okay this is a
joke it's a joke the voting rights act
was specifically designed
to prevent states from preventing black
people from voting this is a new
these are laws of neutral applicability
that affect black citizens and white
citizens
equally okay and the fact is that again
they are more permissive
in many ways than the law was before
this law was passed
okay the doj is ramming it down anyway
to understand how nefarious this is you
need to understand the doj the chief law
enforcement
body in the country right is the highest
level of law enforcement in the country
they prosecute
they are now being used in order to
silence
legislatures in republican-led states
and the judiciary cannot go along with
this
according to the doj itself the united
states complaint contends that several
provisions of senate bill 202 were
adopted with the purpose
of denying or bridging the right to vote
on account of race now they show no
evidence whatsoever none in the entire
complaint that this was done with the
quote unquote purpose of getting black
people not to vote
because they can't show that because it
wasn't and there's nothing in the
consideration of the bill that is very
specific there's nothing about the bill
that is very specific and in fact in
many ways again
this enshrines the ability of people to
vote early it actually opens up
additional days when people can vote
all it does is it includes voter id all
it does
is it prevents more drop boxes which are
very hard to monitor for example
but what exactly is the doj challenging
they're challenging several provisions
of senate bill 202
according to the doj including a
provision banning government entities
from distributing
unsolicited absentee ballot applications
so in other words
they're stopping people from sending to
your house absentee ballot applications
because you should have to request one
if you actually want to vote absentee
it's a way of cracking down on voter
fraud the imposition of costly and
onerous fines on civic organizations
churches and advocacy groups that
distribute follow-up absentee ballot
applications in other words
we are not going to allow people to
simply distribute these things
without the government's purview the
shortening of the deadline to request
absentee ballots to 11 days before
election day which of course is designed
to prevent people from receiving the
absentee ballot the day before and then
it creates all sorts of issues
after the absentee ballot deadline comes
in the requirement that voters who do
not have identification issued by the
georgia department of driver services
photocopy another form of id in order to
request an absentee ballot without
allowing for the use of the last four
digits of a social security number
for such applications okay in other
words voter id
significant limited like none of these
things are racist there's nothing and
the evidence that the doj provides in
its complaint
that racism is at hand here is so scanty
and ridiculous but
again everything has to be about race
because it's all about holding together
the coalition of the supposedly
oppressed with the glue that there is
some
evil oppositional party out there that
is trying to stop you from
feeling your power which is weird coming
from a party that currently controls the
house the senate and the presidency
it doesn't matter again this is all
about building that future demographic
and they're not going to let go of this
argument because it is the great hope of
the democratic party we'll get into more
of this
in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact if you have people
who rely on you you need life insurance
it's that simple if you are a
responsible person you need to make sure
that god forbid something happens you
get
hit by an anvil and like a looney tunes
cartoon now you're dead well you got a
problem
because number one you're dead but
number two your family is gonna go
without your stream of income unless you
have life insurance policy genius makes
it really easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
you could save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius
in fact you could save 1300 bucks or
more per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius an excellent rating on
trustpilot getting started super simple
first head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
at your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and the scheduling
for free policy genius never sells your
information to other companies and
they're not going to add on
extra fees head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro to get started
right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important
to get it right go check them out right
now policygenius.com
shapiro okay so what exactly does the
doj show in order to demonstrate that
georgia is racist here is what they say
in their complaints
sb202's passage followed a series of
historic wins by multiple black
preferred candidates
a significant and well-publicized rise
in black political mobilization and
voting strength
shifting racial demographics in the
state including an increase in the
number of black and latino voters and
changes to the state's typical election
procedures that resulted from the
ongoing pandemic
including a notable increase in absentee
voting okay is any of that evidence that
this was done for purposes of race in
fact
no in fact the last part of the sentence
debunks the first part of the sentence
number one the notion that if a black
preferred candidate wins you can't
change voting procedures
suggests that one racial group is
supposed to run the outcome of elections
which of course is very silly
and the doj is not really even allowed
to make that argument in court because
of course it's racially discriminatory
beyond that it is pretty obvious that
the state did this in response
to the exact pandemic voting procedures
that were put in place
in many cases it turns out in many
states without proper legal auspices
also according to the doj this must be a
racist law because the total black
population in georgia
has been rising and because black voter
turnout rose as well
and also because quote black georgians
undertook substantial new efforts to
harness their political power in 2018
when stacey abrams a black candidate ran
for governor
the 2018 yielded high turnout among
black voters and other voters of color
and specifically encouraged their use of
absentee ballots
also during early voting and on election
day in 2018 advocates and organizations
helped to ensure that voters who faced
long lines
often voters of color had basic food and
water okay this is supposed to be
striking
at the new georgia restriction that
basically says you're not allowed to
bribe people who are in line if they're
150 feet from a polling place
hey all of this there's no evidence for
for any of this demonstrating that the
georgia voting law is racist
at all all they say over and over is
that a bunch of people we like one in
2020 and now they are changing the law
and we don't like that they're changing
the law therefore it's racist
they pretty much say this right the
november 2020 general election in
georgia resulted in historic firsts that
reflect significant demographic and
political shifts in the state for
example
vice president kamala harris became the
first black and indian american vice
president ever elected
okay hold up barack obama ran in 2012
and in in 2008.
he didn't win georgia either time but he
was still the first black president who
was elected so what exactly does georgia
have to do
with vice by the way you don't really
vote for vice president you vote for the
ticket
and really you vote for joe biden at the
top of the ticket but again the doj is
not about enforcing the law the doj is
about enforcing at this point
democratic political preferences and
it's not merely that the doj
is going after for example states like
georgia without any legal basis the doj
is also going after the police the doj
has been attempting to cram down on
police departments all over the country
consent decrees this is the exact same
thing by the way that the obama
administration did
right senator tom cotton has pointed out
that
the doj is now spiked with radicals
right the he tweeted out biden has
stacked the department of justice with
radicals who want to defund the police
which of course is true the doj
officials kristen clarke and vanita
gupta
are the anti-police radicals in question
cotton said quote president biden has
stacked his doj with anti-police
radicals like clark
and gupta america's police officers
already face enough danger in hardship
they shouldn't have to worry if the doj
will also have their back and this of
course is very true if you look at the
records both clark and gupta are
defund the police specialist i mean they
talk repeatedly about the evils
of the american police so again these
are two issues on which americans just
disagree with democrats
democrats do not have the capacity to
let it go in fact they're going to
gaslight you
in the same way barack obama said you
don't oppose his policies it must be
that you're racist
now you have democrats telling you that
if you're worried about crime it must be
because you're either hysterical or
racist it doesn't matter
that we've had the greatest spike in
crime in modern american history
over the period 2019-2021 and it doesn't
matter that that actually began in 2014
2015 with the obama administration
poo-pooing crime and riots in places
like ferguson and baltimore
no if you're in a major city and you're
worried about rising crime it must be
because you're hysterical which is weird
because it turns out that black voters
largely in new york city
voted for eric adams who's the pro cop
candidate in new york city
here's alexander ocasio-cortez the
irrepressible so fresh so faced so
brilliant so many iq points bouncing
around that empty head
is pretty incredible here is aoc
explaining if you're worried about
spiking crime
it's because you are hysterical she
better not be applying that word to
women you're not allowed to apply that
word to women hysterical here she is
we are seeing these headlines about
percentage increases
now i want to say that any amount of
harm is unacceptable
and too much but i also want to make
sure that this hysteria
you know that this doesn't drive a
hysteria and that we look at these
numbers
in context so that we can make
responsible decisions
about what to allocate um in that
context
you're hysterical and look at that look
at the numbers in context because if
there's somebody who's just a
a mistress of complexity and
contextualization
it is the irrepressible alexander
ocasio-cortez
now again if you look at the spike in
murders it didn't start in 2020.
it started in 2019. if you look at the
spike
year over year in crime rates it started
a few years back
so no you're not hysterical if you're
worried about record crime rates
in most of major metropolitan areas with
regard to violent crime
but it doesn't matter you are right
because it must have something to do
with race here's cedric richmond a biden
senior advisor
dismissing republican concerns about
crime
senator graham doesn't have a clue and
let's talk about who defunded the police
when we were in congress last year
trying to pass a rescue plan
i'm sorry not the rescue plan but an
emergency relief plan for cities
that were cash strapped and laying off
police and firefighters it was the
republicans
who objected to it and in fact they
didn't get funding
until the american rescue plan which our
plan allowed
state and local governments to replenish
their police departments and do the
other things that are needed
so look republicans are very good at
staying on talking points of
who says defund the police but the truth
is they defunded the police
okay they're so panicked about their own
positions right now
that they are hysterically projecting
onto republicans defund the police
own it guys you're the ones who want to
bail out rioters last year just to own
it
this is so absurd on its face but again
this is part of the broader democratic
agenda from which they cannot separate
they are ideologically committed to this
agenda we'll get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about a simple
fact right helix sleep mattresses oh
great i've talked to you about them
before but
now they're not just making mattresses
now helix has launched a new company
called all form they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door so what
makes an all form sofa really cool
for starters it is the easiest way you
can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it is spill stain and scratch
resistant you can pick the sofa color
the color of the legs sofa size shape
you make sure it is perfect for you and
your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight seat
sectional so there is something for
everyone and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on if you want
your all form sofa to grow and change
with you when you move
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your door in the past if you wanted to
order a sofa you'd need to hire someone
to come and assemble it in your home
or break your back trying to put it
together yourself all form has simple
quick assembly no tools needed i
do have an all form of self-hate is
fantastic my kids are constantly jumping
on it they compete to sleep on it it's
so good it's a three-seat sofa with
chase in the sand color with espresso
legs
and if getting a sofa without trying it
in store sounds risky don't worry you
have 100 days to decide if you want to
keep it
and also they've got a forever warranty
literally for all time to find your
perfect sofa check out allform.com
i got one for my mom as well that's how
good all form is all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com.com
ben okay so again democrats
ideologically committed to an agenda
that americans just don't like
the latest example of this is of course
their attempt to turn
the george floyd situation into a
referendum for a referendum on
both policing writ large and american
racism writ large
again no evidence presented in the
derrick chauvin trial at
all that derek shoving did this on the
base of race none
they literally provided zero evidence of
this and yet it has become somehow a
talking point
and a point of sort of natural
assumption that derek chovin is the face
of american white racism and george
floyd is the face of black victimization
at the hands of white americans
it's it's kind of wild again no evidence
was provided to that at
all but that's being used as as the
lever with which to
project democrats ideas of quote unquote
equity into the public space and people
don't like it
people don't believe in it it's why
you're seeing all this kickback about
critical race theory the polls show
americans are not interested
in this sort of stuff and then the
second prong of that is that derek
chovin is supposed to represent
police officers writ large and you know
who's pushing this is keith ellison okay
keith ellison is one of the greatest
radicals in the democratic party he's
now the ag
of the state of minnesota but when he
was in congress keith ellison was a
racial radical power excellent
and now he's pushing the idea that he
has a unifying agenda and his unifying
agenda is go after the cops
at the same time democrats are like no
republicans are defunding the police
you've got keith ellison
saying that we need to use prosecutors
to go after cops pretty much everywhere
quote the justice department must also
be a partner in prosecuting cases when
local prosecutions fail to win
convictions
or failed to act as according to keith
ellison in the washington post so it's
not just we have to get local
prosecutors to go after bad cops we have
to have the justice department sit on
top of every police department
in the united states the biden
administration's returned to conducting
investigations
into biased policing patterns and
practices is also welcome
again notice the language it's about
biased policing patterns and practices
right we're not going to demonstrate
actual racism
any evidence of inequality of outcome
more black people being pulled over for
traffic tickets more black people being
arrested for murder that is obviously
an expression of deep-seated american
racism
so democrats can keep pushing this but
it's not going to be particularly
popular particularly popular
and same thing when it comes to the
border again remember the poll that came
from that democratic group
showed that the issues where democrats
were most unpopular were policing
the border public safety issues because
obviously they've decided
to elevate their own bizarre version of
equity over the safety of american
citizens
which disproportionately affects
minority citizens well over the last
three days kamala harris decided that
she was going to finally go down and
visit the border but by the border she
meant somewhere in the general vicinity
of mexico she went down to el paso
which is a border town but is not where
the border crisis is happening
in fact she's sort of jet-setted in she
sat very very many feet away from the
border
and then she talked about how evil the
trump administration was
of course she visited the border just
like she visited europe it's very
exciting stuff
i visited the border over the weekend
you know because i was like down in
miami and that's like the border with
the ocean so it's like
the same thing kind of here's kamala
harris
as you know we inherited a tough
situation
um in fact right here in el paso was the
the launch of the child separation
policy you saw it as it rolled out on
the ground
in real time we have looked at a a
system where
people have been housed in inhumane
conditions over the last
many years an asylum system that has
been broken
and that needs to be reconstructed
yeah she's so bad at all this blaming
trump for everything while you have a
record number of people arriving at the
border
because you've been pushing open borders
rhetoric is pretty wild also
jen saki was asked specifically why
kamala harris was visiting now
and she and why she didn't go to the
border why she went to el paso right
which is a largely democratic town why'd
you go to el paso as opposed to going
down to you know the actual border where
the problems are happening or visiting
at one of the holding facilities or
something and gensake was like because
trump
this is going to be the democrats
constant refrain over and over and guess
what trump ain't president guys you own
it
el paso has um an interesting history
as you may know uh because it was the uh
place where the former president
uh kind of it was a base place of where
he put in place some of his immigration
policies that
we felt were so problematic uh and so
it's a it's a place that has a little
bit of a historical connection
in that regard and it's an opportunity
to uh withdraw a bit of a contrast with
what we're trying to accomplish
oh so it's all about trump always and
forever kevin mccarthy of course then
ripped kamala harris as well he should
here's the house minority leader
soon to be house majority leader by the
way in 2022.
well it seemed like she spent more time
at the airport than she spent at the
border
but to literally say that they inherited
a problem and they made progress
none of those facts play out you have a
border that was secure
you had a new administration that
changed executive orders
and invited people to rush the border
illegally
now in may we had a hundred and eighty
thousand encounters
that was a 21-year record of the illegal
crossings
for the last three months it has
increased
okay and he's right about all this
meanwhile again democrats keep getting
caught up
in their own vision of what america
should be as opposed to what america
is and this is particularly true with
regard to joe biden's agenda so over the
weekend we saw this bizarre situation
which joe biden once again
i mean he is not all there and it is
perfectly obvious at this point that he
is not
all there because he makes comments and
then his team has to rush out of the
wings
and wheel old joe back feed him his
cream of wheat put him down for a nap
and then they have like ron klein come
out and clarify what exactly
he meant or they put out a written
statement where joe biden can't fumble
over his own words and get into a
physical
fist fight with the teleprompter it's
insane so you remember that
late last week on thursday there was a
group of republicans and democrats and
joe biden they all came together at the
white house and they announced they had
a bipartisan deal on infrastructure
and kamala harris was creepily hanging
out like behind a pillar
kind of staring at uh at the man whose
job she will eventually
take don't be a food taster at the white
house gang it's a bad bad job
okay so you remember that and you
remember they announced we have a
bipartisan deal and then
within just a couple of hours joe biden
was out there saying well
yeah we have a we have a bipartisan deal
on this part but i'm
i'm not going to sign that unless we
also pass
through reconciliation this giant
builder
can everybody won't wait hold up that's
not a bipartisan deal then
if i say to you i promise to buy from
you this this used car
and you say i'm willing to sell you this
used car and i say yes i will buy from
you this used car also
i insist that you sell me your house at
a price i want to pay that's not a deal
you've now changed the deal
so joe biden did that and there's a lot
of consternation on both sides of the
aisle
it looked as though he had undercut mitt
romney and susan collins and all the
rest of the republicans because all the
rest of the republicans were like um
here we are holding the bag out here and
we came out here on behalf of
bipartisanship
and you used us in order to have your
photo op and then you just undercut us
so no deal
right behind closed doors i am sure sure
that what republicans
were saying to biden was listen if you
insist on this being part of a package
deal
we're not going through with any you're
not going to get past the filibuster not
only that we're not going to vote for it
so then joe biden had to walk it back
according to the new york times it was
all going according to president biden's
tight role plan to pass the most
ambitious economic agenda in generations
right until the moment that mr biden a
politician with a history of rogue
comments
veered off script understand the reason
that biden did this is because he's more
afraid of aoc and bernie sanders
than he is of his actual base that the
people who are closer to center left or
the people who just want to get things
done in a practical way he's scared
crapless of the radical democrats saying
that he is insufficiently submitted to
the
committed to the cause because remember
joe biden's agenda he knows he's not a
two-term president
if he makes it through a first term and
if he runs for a second term he
certainly is not making it through a
second term
so he knows he's not making it eight
years so it's i need to be a historic
president
right here right now and if i'm deprived
of that by these republicans who are
filibustering
then i'm going to make my mark by
basically shellacking them over and over
and over
so that's why he walked back to
bipartisan deal after weeks of
closed-door negotiations according to
the new york times mr biden strode to
the cameras on white house driveway on
thursday
flanked by an equal number of democratic
and republican lawmakers to
proudly announce an overall
infrastructure agreement totaling 1.2
trillion dollars over eight years that
could cement his legacy as a bipartisan
deal maker
biden and his top aides had successfully
struck a limited agreement with key
central senators to rebuild roads and
bridges while carefully signaling the
liberals he still intended to embrace a
measure likely to gain only democratic
support to spend trillions more on
climate education child care and other
economic priorities
it was and i told you so a moment for a
president who's supremely confident in
his ability to navigate
legislative negotiations but in the
stray comment during a news conference
an hour or later the president blurted
out he would not approve the compromise
without the partisan bill he said if
that's the only thing that comes to me
i'm not finding it
i'm not signing the bipartisan bill and
forgetting about
the rest come on man
it may not seem like much says the new
york times it was enough to up end
biden's proud bipartisan moment
on the one hand he was saying out loud
what liberals in his party wanted to
hear that's the center for senators and
republicans
it made explicit a notion that had only
been hinted at before that biden not
only intended to sign a second more
ambitious package but that he would also
go
so far as to veto their bipartisan plan
if the larger bill did not materialize
senator susan collins said we never had
an inkling that would be any kind of
linkage
we always knew there'd be another bill
but not that the success of the
infrastructure package was going to be
in any way
dependent on the other bill so the white
house had to engage in damage control
and then they had to walk it back
and then biden had to concede that he
had misspoken he had not misspoken guys
he's saying the quiet part out loud
which is that he intends to shiv
republicans directly in the back which
is why they never should have gone along
with this dumb deal
in the first place mitt romney always of
generous spirits
suggested of course that now he takes
biden at his word that he's de-linking
the two issues
i do take the president at his word and
and over the weeks and weeks of
negotiations with democrats and with the
white house
on an infrastructure bill the the
president's other agenda was never
linked to the infrastructure effort uh
we came to an agreement on the
infrastructure effort in a way that
i think is really impressive as you know
uh it it
is true infrastructure bridges roads
rail
electric uh utility support and so forth
and uh and without raising taxes and so
this is a bill which stands on its own
okay well we'll see if the bill stands
on its own or if joe manchin and kristen
cinema are just going to quietly go
along with what it was that biden was
saying in the first place
and the democrats let the democrats own
it i don't understand why republicans
would work with these people just
don't give them what they want don't
give them the veneer of bipartisanship
on what is
a heavily partisan agenda and you say oh
well you know we saved over the course
of a decade
200 billion dollars okay and you also
gave him the political wins that he can
go out and continue to win
on the basis of a lie which is that he's
a bipartisan president when he very much
is not okay in just a second we are
going to get to the
spoiled brat problem in american public
life it is a very
very serious problem first the daily
wire has several open positions for our
in-house team in nashville in particular
we are looking for a human resources
coordinator to join
our hr team this person will be
dedicated to providing administrative
support to daily wires hr manager as
well as the hr department at large
he or she will have the opportunity to
be exposed to and provide support on a
wide variety of hr related tasks and
projects
in a high energy fast-paced work
environment if this sounds like
something for you
then check it out we are looking for
someone with at least two years of
previous professional
hr experience in a similar role somebody
who's highly organized detail-oriented
possesses excellent
interpersonal skills it's a full-time
in-office position in nashville
tennessee it's a great place to work
candidates should apply through
dailywire.com check out all of our job
listings over there by the way
dailywire.com
careers also if you missed my episode of
sunday special yesterday now is your
chance to catch up
i'm joined by none other than russell
brand actor turned podcaster we discuss
everything from philosophy to politics
to spirituality
and his own tumultuous experience with
addiction it's a fantastic conversation
it's out now for your listening pleasure
it's my favorite thing to do it's a
discussion it is not a debate and
i think that we go through a lot of
topics where we disagree in a respectful
and interesting manner go check it out
at dailywire.com or on my youtube
channel ben shapiro
daily where members get access to
special bonus content from sunday
special episodes
don't miss out join daily wire today
also if you haven't noticed history is
constantly being erased rewritten
you don't need to look much further than
the 1619 project to see that the left is
attempting to transform history
to own the present so it is now up to us
to make sure that history is documented
in a proper
way otherwise future generations aren't
going to be aware of real history for
example
they're not going to be aware of supreme
court justice clarence thomas and his
story he tells that story in the
documentary
created equal you'll remember it was
de-listed by amazon during black history
month of course of course the
documentary is now
only available to daily wire members so
if you want more stories that diverge
from the accepted political narrative go
to dailywire.com
subscribe get 20 off your new membership
with code
justice again amazon's you listed the
video daily wire check it up
we're streaming it ourselves make sure
it's great for your kids by the way if
they want to know about
real american history over the course of
the last 80 or so years go check
out dailywire.com get a membership and
watch created equal it is an excellent
documentary
join now dailywire.com subscribe with
codejustice for 20 off your membership
and get ready for an excellent
documentary also you have all the other
great stuff that you get with membership
you get candace's show candace owens
or our first film run hide fight or my
new series debunked where i debunk
leftist myths in 15 minutes or less all
sorts of good stuff happening and
brand new content being added all the
time when you become a member
dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20 off using
code justice don't wait
start streaming today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so where is all this coming from in
our political life where is this
this deep feeling that democrats are
going to be able to cobble together
this newfound majority where's it coming
from because barack obama was a signal
figure
figure in american political history he
was very good at his at his
rhetorical job he was an excellent
campaigner he himself had unique
personal characteristics that no other
american candidate
seems able to sort of put together so
where is all this democratic confidence
coming from that they're going to be
able to be victorious with such a
radical agenda that most americans
really don't like
and the answer is i think i think it
lies in a sense
that most americans are disconnected
from the rest of the world and from
their own history
they're disconnected in the sense that
they do not understand how far we have
come
they do not understand what it is like
to live at any other place on earth and
this leads to an awful lot
of ingratitude and so you can look at
your own life it's so easy to look at
your own life
and see all the problems with your own
life and and never think about the fact
that you are living in like the top one
percent of people who have ever lived on
planet earth
and in fact if you're living in the
united states right now
you are still in terms of global
population living
in like the top even if you're at like
the very lowest end
of the american economic spectrum you're
still living in the top
quintile for sure of people who are
living on planet earth right now there
are lots of other countries on planet
earth
and a lot of those other countries
people are living in absolute horror and
probation
and poverty and repression by their
government and yet there's this
enormous sense of ingratitude that
democrats bank on in order to push for
the idea that america
must undergo some sort of fundamental
systemic change gratitude
is an understanding that you owe
something to the past and not only that
you owe something to the past maybe
people who came before you knew some
things
but ingratitude believes that the entire
system is corrupt
and just like a small child my kids
they're ungrateful on a regular basis
and it's because they don't understand
what they have they don't understand how
good their life is
they're comparing their life to some
utopian vision of what their life would
be if they got everything that they
wanted
now their children so what they want is
usually very stupid but that's also true
it turns out of many people on the left
many of the things that they actually
want in life
are not particularly beneficial for a
society more importantly however what it
really relies on
is an is a failure of understanding
about the society in which they live
and a belief that there are other
societies out there that are so much
better if only we
did x or there's a utopia that we're
comparing ourselves to
and we'll never reach the utopia but
we'll get to we can
grow closer to that utopia by
disregarding the past that brought us
this far now none of this is an argument
that we should always
eschew change and we should never look
at changing our systems but
it means that you ought to go carefully
if you recognize all the wonderful
things
in your life and all the wonderful
things about this country you might be a
little bit careful
about ripping on the country broadly
speaking about
deciding that all of the systems of the
united states are a serious problem
and yet because people live within the
system they don't understand the
greatness
of the system they seem to assume that
they are doing something positive
when they believe that the system itself
is inherently corrupt
and rigged and terrible okay so this
comes to mind thanks to a couple of
stories
over the weekend first i just want to
give you just an a note
of what it's like to live in other
places in the world and it is amazing if
you just read a book
about what goes on in other places in
the world suddenly you might discover
that america is a pretty damned fine
place
it really is and there's certain things
we take for granted in american life
that you can't take for granted nearly
any other place on earth except for some
areas of western europe and like canada
and australia and that's it
right every every other place on earth
is plagued by issues far worse
than the united states and so to take an
example
over the weekend apple daily shuttered
apple daily was a major hong kong
newspaper
hong kong was a free state it was
guaranteed
its freedom by a treaty between the
chinese government and the british
government when the british decided to
abdicate all responsibility in hong kong
in the 1990s
and china recently just basically walked
in and took the place over and now has
subjected it to absolute communist
privation
so that means they shut down the english
edition of apple daily
hong kong's biggest pro democracy
newspaper just shut down
willy nilly and we talk in the united
states you hear all these members of the
press oh trump he was gonna shut it
there is no danger to the free press in
the united states none on a serious
level
the only danger to dissemination of
ideas is through sort of
corporate censorship but certainly not
the government stepping in and just
shutting down newspapers willy-nilly the
way things are happening in hong kong
right now the former managing editor was
then arrested at the hong kong airport
on charges of collusion
according to axios apple daily shuttered
last week following the freezing of its
assets under china's national security
law
journalist waikong's arrest comes days
after police arrested an apple daily
columnist who publishes under the name
of liping for allegedly
conspiring to collude with foreign
countries or foreign forces to endanger
national security
under the law they also arrested seven
journalists at the news outlet which was
unfounded which was founded by the
imprisoned tycoon jimmy lie
under the law the authorities charged
lie and other pro-democracy activists
after they organized a massive protest
in 2019
so they just shut down the newspaper
william and this sort of stuff happens
routinely
all over the earth but if you look at
how americans act
i'm sorry but a huge percentage of
americans are just spoiled brats they're
just spoiled brats
so to take a quick example of such
spoiled
bratishness there's a woman named
gwenberry
okay she's in she's a professional
hammer thrower
right so she's trying out for the
olympics the olympic trials and number
one
in order to dedicate the amount of time
necessary to become a very specific
skill-setted person
like throwing a hammer which by the way
they're not a lot of like job applicants
for ken youth roy hammer
in the united states just not a lot of
open jobs for hammer thrower
in the united states which means you
have to dedicate a significant amount of
time to a pursuit
that does not pay off economically okay
which demonstrates again
a certain level of wealth in a nation
typically when people live in absolute
probation they don't actually have the
time
to dedicate enormous amounts of time to
learning to throw a hammer properly
okay so gwen berry was competing in the
olympic trials
and she came in third and she came in
third in the olympic trials i mean she's
going to the olympics but probably is
not expected to do particularly well
since she came in third in her own
country before we even get to
international
competition but even if she came in
third at the olympic trials
she came in first in the
self-involvement olympics because it
turns out
that they have a pre-scheduled every day
during the olympic
trials at like 5 20 every day or 5 25
every day they play the national anthem
well it turned out that she finished her
event
at about the time that the national
anthem started playing and so everybody
in the stadium turned
and started putting their hand over
their heart gwen barry did not
right gwen berry decided that it would
the national anthem was just it's too
terrible it's too awful her life is too
awful as a
hammer thrower in the olympic trials for
her to pay attention
to the national not only that she said
she found it insulting she said
she felt targeted that it was all that
it was all rigged that it was designed
to make her feel bad so she turned away
during the national anthem and then of
course we understand what the real
rationale is here
the real rationale is she wants to make
a buck because again spoiled brats in
american society make an awful lot of
cash they do really really well the more
you whine about america in the united
states the more we reward you here
in the united states another mark of a
decadent society
right here she she she's proud of
herself so she tweeted out this picture
of herself in a in a particular
in a in a particular pose right with her
hand on her hip
and she's kind of throwing out her head
and she's staring directly into camera
right she knows exactly where the
cameras are all of the other people
on the podium are staring up at the flag
everybody else in the stadium is staring
up the flag she knows
precisely where the camera is she's
staring directly at it right it's a
direct in the camera look
and then she tweeted out stop playing
with me
oh the heroism oh the absolute amazing
heroism
of this person the self-involvement of
this person i mean seriously
you finished third lady it's not like
you finished first okay but
then she held up a shirt saying activist
athlete oh my
wow wow and what change she has affected
in the united states what unbelievable
change she has affected in the united
states
listen it's a free country she can do
exactly what she wants and we are
perfectly free to rip on the fact that
this is a person who is utterly
disconnected from the reality in which
she
and most other americans live which is
you should be extremely grateful for all
the problems the united states has
the the simple gratitude of you know not
being a horse's ass during the national
anthem
seems like a baseline minimum to being a
mensch to being like a decent person
but apparently not because again we live
in a very spoiled society where people
have
no sense of context whatsoever at all
at all that bodes poorly for the united
states but here's the thing i think
there will blow back to this spoil brash
behavior tends to earn the ire of the
american public democrats are about to
earn it
in uh in terms of politics alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael mull's
show today he discusses joy reid denying
the existence
of critical race theory you can hear
more details about that story over on
michael's show that is available right
now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
our nation's top military brass goes
woke
an olympian disrespects the flag and aoc
gaslights on the crime search check it
out on the michael knowles show